good afternoon my name is Luca villas
Bailey and I'm from the Religious
Studies department and it's my distinct
privilege and pleasure to welcome you
all to on behalf of the Terry lecture
committee to the second installment of
this year's Dwight H Terry lectureship
titled cosmic society the new universe
and the human future in these
presentations our distinguished guests
nancy allen abrams and Joel are primack
will present the emerging scientific
understanding of the universe and our
place in it no one and perhaps even know
couple could banter answer to Dwight H
Terry's charged that the lectures
explore how scientific knowledge and
philosophical insight inform religion
and religions application to human
welfare they have co-authored articles
on quantum cosmology in Kabbalah as well
as numerous articles on science policies
space policy and the cultural
implications of modern cosmology nancy
allen abrams is an attorney and
philosopher of science who in addition
to her prominent work on the
intersection of science and politics
engages the question of how to place the
discoveries of modern cosmology into a
cultural context and she's also in
composer and musician and several of her
musical compositions will accompany
videos shown in the Terry lectures and
today it will be the music to the last
video a professor of physics at
University of California Santa Cruz
drool our Premack is one of the creators
of the modern picture of the universe he
contributed to what we call the Standard
Model of particle physics and is one of
the principal organ or originator Xand
developers of the theory of cold dark
matter as a specialist in the formation
of and evolution of galaxies and the
nature of dark matter professor primex
current research uses supercomputers to
simulate and visualize the evolution of
the universe under various assumptions
together you co-authored the book the
view from the center of the universe
discovering our extraordinary place in
the cosmos and you co Todd
popular course called cosmology and
culture at the University of California
Santa Cruz for more than a decade and
given your opening lecture yesterday I
have no doubts as to why this course was
so popular you dare to ask large scale
questions and you call on us to develop
a vision of the cosmos that allows us to
confront humanity's pressing global
problems in all of this you remind us
that our role as scholars in
universities can be not only to produce
true statements about the universe but
also to shine light on to our humanity
in a world that is at once
interconnected open for analysis and
profoundly beautiful let us now listen
to the second lecture entitled Stardust
plus time equals ask Thank You Nancy and
thank you Joe thanks very much for that
wonderful introduction and thanks to the
audience for your attention and if
anyone has a cell phone that hasn't been
turned off please turn them off now what
are we human beings made of literally
are we made of flesh and blood sugar and
spice and everything nice to become a
cosmic society we need to appreciate at
a much deeper level what we are and how
we fit into the universe we humans are
made of a rainbow of atoms that were
cooked up inside ancient stars or formed
during supernovas and spewed out to
travel through space for billions of
years to evolve into our planet and us
we humans are ninety percent Stardust by
weight and ten percent hydrogen which is
mostly an hour h2o we and the ground we
walk on are literally made of Stardust
well into the 20th century scientists
believe that everything is made of atoms
and everything on earth actually is but
earth is
really a typical of the universe and the
way things are put together here is not
a good basis for extrapolation let's
come back to the cosmocorps Oh Boris
that we introduced yesterday in the
first lecture as we show then on vast
size scales the laws of physics that
control events are not the same as in
daily life on earth or on atomic scales
size makes all the difference so we may
be made of atoms but what's the rest of
the universe made of without knowing
that we can't possibly imagine how we
fit in the theory that answers this
question is the double dark theory that
we discussed yesterday it tells us that
the two dominant ingredients in the
cosmic recipe are dark matter and dark
energy both on earthly things whose
nature is still not well understood we
Stardust beings are the beneficiaries of
dark matter and dark energy because
their interaction over billions of years
has shaped the universe the other
crucial ingredient in this equation is
time and in this lecture we'll explain
first what the ingredients of the
universe are and second how to think
about cosmic time we explained in
lecture one that we humans are close to
the midpoint of all possible sizes in
this lecture we'll explain that we're
made of the rarest material in the
universe Stardust and that we are at the
centre of the visible universe gradually
as we integrate these characteristics in
our minds we begin to understand how we
fit into a universe that at first defies
intuition this is what the universe
looks like to the Hubble Space Telescope
it's very beautiful but it's extremely
misleading because all it shows is light
and all light can reveal is half of one
percent of what's actually out there the
other 99 /
point five percent of the universe is
invisible we call this symbol the
pyramid of all visible matter and of
course we have borrowed it from the
pyramid on the back of the dollar bill
we're using it here though to represent
everything that we can see in the
universe with all our instruments the
volume of each section of the pyramid is
proportional to the amount of that
ingredient in the visible universe the
ribbon at the bottom says in Latin the
new order of the ages and that's what
this new universe picture is going to
become almost all the atoms in the
universe are just the two lightest kinds
hydrogen and helium that's what comes
out of the Big Bang in roughly the
proportion by mass three parts hydrogen
to one part helium they fill the entire
bottom section of the pyramid the
hydrogen helium became stars and inside
those stars nuclear processes created
new kinds of atoms like carbon oxygen
iron and all the other heavy elements
these heavy elements are ejected by
dying stars and they become star dust
floating through interstellar space you
see up on the left the periodic table of
the elements hydrogen and helium or what
the stars are mostly made of and all
these other elements are the Stardust
the iron atoms in our blood carrying
oxygen at this very moment to ourselves
came largely from exploding white dwarf
stars that's on the right the remnant of
one of those explosions while the oxygen
itself came mainly from massive stars
exploding as supernovas these are
examples of the remnants of supernova
explosions most of the carbon in the
carbon dioxide we exhale on every breath
came from planetary nebulas the death
clouds of middle sized stars like the
Sun it takes us our millions or billions
of years to produce a comparatively tiny
number of heavy atoms and these bits of
Stardust then drift across time and
space to come together to incarnate us
the cat's eye nebula in the lower left
is a particularly pretty example of a
planetary
nebula let's look at it first on a
larger scale and then zoom in to the
cat's eye so that's a large scale image
and that is the cat's eye let's zoom in
you
all its left of the star ultimately is a
white dwarf at the center all the rest
of the star is blown off in these
colourful clouds of Stardust's that
surround the star on any planet in the
galaxy or any other galaxy wherever you
find watery seas and land there will be
sandy beaches this is because oxygen and
silicon are two of the most abundant
heavy atoms produced before a star
explodes in a supernova free floating in
space they combine with the hydrogen
thats everywhere making h2o and SiO 2
water and the sand the travel together
and become incorporated into new worlds
the capstone of the pyramid the floating
part at the top represents the mass of
the star dust compared to that of
hydrogen and helium it's about two
percent of the total the eye and the
capstone represents the miniscule amount
of Stardust in us that is in all
intelligent creatures and it's the only
cosmic ingredient not drawn to scale
since if it were drawn the scale will be
a microscopic point this pyramid
represents everything visible in the
universe but what's all the rest the
other ninety nine and a half percent we
call this symbol the cosmic density
pyramid because it contains everything
that gives the universe density
including not only matter but energy as
you can see the pyramid of all visible
matter is just the tip of a huge
underground pyramid the visible atoms
are just half of one percent the
invisible atoms add up to an additional
roughly four percent it turns out there
are five different ways that we can
measure the total atomic content of the
universe and they all agree so we're
quite sure that we have this accounting
right the vast majority of the cosmic
density is invisible stuff dark matter
and dark energy making up about
ninety-five percent most of the matter
holding our own galaxy and other
galaxies together
cold dark matter except for except
gravitationally Dark Matter hardly
interacts with anything including itself
so it can never make anything complex it
just makes big halos as we call them
which are blobs of dark matter that
surround and permeate each and every
galaxy dark matter neither emits light
of stars do nor reflects it as gas
clouds do nor absorbs it as dust does it
also doesn't emit or absorb x-rays radio
waves or any other form of radiation
that astronomers have detected we know
it's there only because its immense
gravitation dark matter is not a good
name in fact since the stuff isn't dark
its invisible it's transparent but
whatever it's called it controls the
origin and evolution of galaxies
galaxies clusters and superclusters of
galaxies the largest portion of the
pyramid seventy percent or so of the
density of the universe is dark energy
this is the most powerful ingredient in
the universe and yet until 1998 we
weren't even sure it exists although it
was a hypothetical possibility that I
and other astrophysicist study dark
energy is connected to the expansion of
the universe before I explain it I'm
going to take a step back and explain
first what it means that the universe is
expanding all distant galaxies are being
carried away from our Milky Way galaxy
by expanding space itself imagine that
we live in galaxy a we see galaxies be
moving away from us with a certain speed
galaxy siii twice as far away moving
twice as fast the arrows twice as long
galaxy d three times as far away moving
three times as fast but now let's look
at the situation from the viewpoint of
galaxies be galaxy be seized our galaxy
a moving away at a certain speed and the
galaxy on the other side equally far
away moving with the same speed in the
opposite direction and then galaxy d
twice as far as galaxy siii moving twice
as fact
fast and so on so the situation looks
the same from every galaxy every
observer sees exactly the same pattern
in the motion of distant galaxies that's
how a uniformly expanding universe works
of course this picture just shows one
dimension here's a two-dimensional
picture with time increasing upward
notice that the galaxies aren't
expanding just the distances between
them most astronomers assume that the
expansion of the universe was gradually
slowing down because of the mutual
attraction of everything in it but in
1998 the amazing discovery was made that
the expansion of the universe is not
slowing down at all but accelerating
dark energy seems to be a property of
space that make space repel itself the
more space there is and of course
increasing amounts of space are
inevitable in an expanding universe the
more repulsion the more repulsion the
faster pace space expands the faster it
expands the more space the more
repulsion this leads to an exponentially
increasing expansion which may go on
forever until only about ten years ago
astronomy students were usually taught
that there are three possible futures
for the universe one it can expand
forever at a constant rate too it can
slow down forever asymptotically that is
the rate of expansion would get closer
and closer to zero without ever reaching
it that's shown by this curve getting
the slope getting lower and lower or
three if there's enough matter in the
universe the gravitation of all that
matter would eventually slow the
expansion to a halt and the universe
would begin to contract so it halts
there and then it starts to contract in
the figure all the curves cross at the
point labeled now it's been set up that
way when the universe is a size the size
it is now represented by one the third
possibility led people to speculate
about whether there would be a big
crunch as everything came back together
again
and if so whether there could be another
Big Bang odd infinitum I bring this all
up because all these alternatives have
been talked about so widely and you
should understand that we now know
they're all wrong which reflects the
rather primitive state of cosmology
until recently now we have convincing
evidence that the expansion of the
universe is actually accelerating so
it's that red picture what's happening
is that the universe first slows down
and then start speeding up the test of a
theory so how certain are we scientists
at this whole kooky sounding double dark
theory is right the test of a theory is
not how logical beautiful or on the
other hand weird or unlikely it sounds
the test is how accurate are its
predictions the double dark Theory has
predicted the observation successfully
for more than 20 years and as huge
amounts of new data have become
available more recently from the
wonderful telescopes on the ground like
the Keck Observatory in Hawaii and in
space by couple Space Telescope the
predictions have continued to be right
crucial evidence has also come from
satellites observing not light but the
heat radiation of the Big Bang I'll show
you some of the evidence that is
convinced astronomers all over the world
now what's plotted here it's called
power is basically the frequency of
spots of a given size this is the sphere
surrounding us of the cosmic background
radiation the heat radiation of the Big
Bang and the different colors correspond
to very slight differences in
temperature in different directions
differences of a few millions of a
degree the large scales many degrees
were studied by the cobe satellite whose
results first became available in
nineteen eighty to nineteen ninety two
rather starting in 2003 the Wilkinson
microwave anisotropy probe and NASA
satellite like Kobe started to release
its data
and the most recent data release in 2008
is represented by the white dots on this
diagram what this shows is that one
degree size patches are particularly
favored half degree is disfavored third
video areas favored quarter degree is
disfavored and so on now the important
thing is to realize that this curve the
prediction of the double dark theory was
calculated before any of this data
became available and the fact that every
single point lies where it was predicted
to also in these ground-based
experiments that probe smaller scales is
a triumph for the theory we now have a
new satellite the Planck satellite that
will soon start reporting its data and
it will cover this region with greater
precision and it'll be interesting to
see if it continues to agree with the
predictions I think most astrophysicists
expect that it will I certainly do so
what this shows is that the double dark
Theory correctly predicted the
properties of the heat radiation of the
Big Bang the cosmic background radiation
but the same Theory also correctly
predicted the distribution of matter on
all science skills that astronomers can
study from smaller than galaxies to
galaxies to clusters of galaxies to
superclusters of galaxies all the way
out to the cosmic horizon that's why we
take the double dark Theory so seriously
I could show you a great deal more
evidence what happened according to the
double dark theory is that in the early
stages of the universe there was
relatively little dark energy because
there was relatively little space the
universe hadn't had time to expand very
much however there was the same amount
of dark matter then as now for the first
nine billion years or so the
gravitational attraction of the dark
matter did in fact slow the rate of
expansion but the expansion was still
going on producing more space and so the
dark matter thinned out but dark energy
apparently doesn't thin out perhaps
because it's a property of space itself
it's relative importance thus increases
now the repulsive effect of the dark
energy has surpassed the gravitational
attraction of the Dark Matter as the
dominant effect in the universe on large
scales the turning point was about five
billion years ago coincidentally just
about when our solar system was forming
now let me just give you a simpler way
of thinking about this imagine that the
entire universe is an ocean filled with
dark energy and on that ocean their sale
billions of ghostly ships made out of
dark matter at the tips of only the
tallest masts of the largest ships are
little tiny beacons of light and those
beacons of light are what we call
galaxies with Hubble Space Telescope we
can only see the beacons we can't see
the ships and we can't see the ocean but
we know they're there through theory
specifically the double dark theory that
Joel's been talking about now this
oceanic imagery has a certain residence
with ancient Egyptian and Biblical
cosmologies because both of them also
envisioned that the primeval water an
unearthly substance not normal water
predated the creation and continued to
surround the world the creation was in
the middle the world was created in the
midst of this primeval water but here's
the twist in our modern version dark
matter is indeed primeval and it came
out of the Big Bang and it does surround
our galaxy but dark energy is creating
more of itself all the time and the
larger the universe expands the more
dark energy there is and the faster it's
being created now this we could leave it
here we could just say oh how
interesting but if we take dark energy
seriously it means we have to begin
thinking in a new way about what we
normally call outer space most people
use the phrase outer space to mean
anything outside Earth's atmosphere but
this communicates a very static picture
of the universe it's left out the whole
idea of expansion if we think of outer
space
as starting outside Earth's atmosphere
then we need to think of it as stopping
at the edge of our local Group of
galaxies now galaxies are often bound
together by gravity in clumps and big
clumps are called galaxy clusters and
little clumps are called groups galaxy
groups our Milky Way is part of a small
group called the local group which
includes two big galaxies Milky Way and
Andromeda plus a lot of smaller galaxies
our local group is bound together by
gravity so it doesn't expand anymore it
travels as a unit in the universal
expansion yes so the husband says his
wife don't feel bad Loretta the entire
universe is expanding well you know it's
a great excuse but it's wrong because
there is no expansion on earth or inside
our entire galaxy outside the local
group though the universe is expanding
faster and faster gravitationally bound
groups though like our local group are
not expanding their contracting and as
the gravity of the galaxies continues it
makes them fall together and they will
eventually merge and so all the space
inside our entire galaxy and between our
galaxy and the other members of the
local group is a special kind of space
because it's been tamed by gravity
outside our local group lies the real
outer space wild space on a huge scale
dark energy is tearing apart all large
structures and accelerating the rate of
expansion wild space is carrying
hundreds of billions of galaxies away
from our local group in all directions
so here's this guy it's drunk he's
sitting on the soup and he says to his
friends it's a little hard to read
quarks neutrinos Mason's all those damn
particles you can't see that's what
drove me to drink but now I can see them
and there's great truth to this because
now we too can see what cannot be seen
to show you how wild and tame space work
we have to visualize the invisible but
we're going to do this not with
the help of alcohol but with computer
simulations so I'm going to show a video
of dark of a Dark Matter simulation that
illustrates what Nancy's has been
talking about the simulation shows a
small part of the universe initially
you'll see it expanding but soon the
screen is filled with a region that's
become bound together by gravity and it
stops expanding so watch the video and
see if you can tell when it stops
expanding
you
let's look at a few stills so they're
about 49 million years after the Big
Bang it's just starting to expand in
this video here about three hundred
seventy four million years it's
expanding very rapidly by about 2.2 gige
years that's billions of years the
central region has actually stopped
expanding and this material is flowing
toward it here's that same central
region now about 6.7 billion years after
the Big Bang about seven billion years
ago and the central region has pretty
much stopped expanding but this piece is
still sliding away if we look somewhat
later now nine and a half billion years
after the Big Bang that piece has almost
completely left this field of view this
region has gotten a little bit bigger
but that's not because it's expanded its
because material is flowing into this
region none if we look today that's that
same one we were just looking at about
nine and a half billion years and this
is today 13.7 billion years this is tame
space this is wild space it's still
expanding so this is to illustrate wild
and tame space let's look again at that
video and this time try to imagine
what's the tame space and what's the
wild space as the video goes on
so in these dark-matter simulation
visualizations what looks bright is in
reality completely invisible we're just
looking at Dark Matter the video uses
brightness to represent the density of
the dark matter the brighter or region
appears the more dark matter it contains
now I'm going to show you a more
elaborate simulation in these videos
we're going to look at the evolution of
a region about a hundred million light
years across from soon after the Big
Bang until the present but if we tried
to show the expansion you wouldn't be
able to see what was happening until the
region grew into nearly its present size
you can't see what's going on here or
here so on the bottom we expand all of
these up to full size and when we do
that we're showing the evolution of
structure but not the expansion we
astronomers call this working in
comoving coordinates we will also rotate
the volume in the video that I'm about
to show slowly to help show the three
dimensions there's a clock in the lower
left corner showing the number of
billions of years ago now you'll notice
that the Dark Matter starts very smooth
but just a couple billion years after
the beginning a tremendous amount of
structure has formed that just becomes
more distinct and starts to split up as
time goes on it turns out that what's
happening is matter is being attracted
to what we might call wrinkles in space
that are laid down by processes that
occur in the earliest moments of the
universe a period that we call cosmic
inflation we're going to come back to
that in the next lecture and also in the
last lecture but here's the simulation
so already just a billion years after
the Big Bang you can see a lot of
structure you can see these filaments of
Dark Matters starting to form the bright
yellow places mark where galaxies are
forming remember you're only seeing
invisible Dark Matter the computer is
making it visible to us but notice that
where these filaments cross you get a
large number of these bright spots where
lots of galaxies are forming and those
are the super clusters and at their
centers the clusters of galaxies our
galaxy doesn't lie in a cluster it just
lies in a small group along one of these
filaments you just saw how the cosmic
web of dark matter forms and that at the
intersections of the filaments the
density is much greater that's where
clusters of galaxies form now we're
going to look at a video that my
colleagues and I just finished about two
weeks ago earlier this year we ran what
is I think a path-breaking simulation we
call it the bolshoy simulation because
when my Russian collaborator anatoly
clippin suggested that name we all burst
out laughing bull shite is thought by
many Americans to mean ballet or a
particular ballet troupe actually in
Russian it just means big the [ __ ]
theater is the big theater in Moscow and
it's where the famous Russian ballet
troupe often performs and this is the
highest resolution big simulation of the
evolution of the double dark universe
that has yet been performed in this
simulation every dark matter halo that
could host a visible galaxies is shown
first I'm going to just look at a bunch
of still pictures and zoom in to see
some of the small structure
you
you
now we're going to fly through a region
of the simulation about a hundred
million light years across surrounding a
dark matter halo hosting a large cluster
of galaxies
there's the region hosting the cluster
now the camera is moving in but still
rotating around
we're in the process of analyzing the
simulation outputs statistical sets are
showing that the distribution of dark
matter haloes in this and similar
simulations looks exactly like the
actual distribution both nearby and far
away in the universe now I want to show
you a magnificent simulation called the
Aquarius simulation by a European group
led by Volker springle it simulates the
formation of a milky way size dark
matter halo which is ten times smaller
across than the region I just showed you
in these sorts of simulations a lot
happens much earlier because this
relatively small region stops expanding
fairly soon we can show the expansion in
this video in fact the camera moves
slowly closer to the central dark matter
halo again we're rotating the image to
show the three-dimensional structures
this is the time we're starting at about
80 million years after the Big Bang now
120 million years 0 point 12 billion
years this is the redshift for
astronomers are familiar with that this
whole region is going to collapse to
form the dark matter halo of a milky way
size galaxy so it starts out very
filamentary but you'll see that the
filaments are steadily getting thicker
and drawing together
it's fun to follow individual dark
matter haloes and what you'll see is
that they flow through the dense regions
and then out the other side but they
lose some of their particles some of
their mass every time they do that Dark
Matter lumps can go right through each
other as the camera moves in this region
representing 500 kiloparsecs that's
that's comparable in size to the dark
matter halo of our galaxy that's getting
larger because we're moving slowly
closer to the center
now this is a object that will host a
fairly large galaxy some of these are
going to be swallowed by the forming
Milky Way and their stars will just
become part of the stars of our Milky
Way galaxy something like ten percent of
the stars in the Milky Way did not form
in the Milky Way and others are going to
be satellite galaxies of the Milky Way
more and more of these satellite
galaxies are being discovered with more
powerful telescopes and better search
techniques so how big is our galaxy the
visible part of the galaxy that's how
big it's pretty small that's a hundred
thousand light-years across this is
about 1.6 million light-years across
that 500 kiloparsecs this is what we
call the relaxed or V realized region of
our Milky Way size halo and this part is
found to it but it hasn't relaxed yet
gravitationally so there you see how
tiny the visible galaxies is compared to
the dark matter haloes
we've introduced the symbols of the
cosmocorps Oh Boris which represents all
possible sizes in the universe and the
cosmic density pyramid which represents
all the ingredients in the universe and
both capture aspects of the real
universe that are hard to visualize but
neither of them represents the crucial
aspect that animates the universe time
now we're going to switch back from
computer simulations of invisible Dark
Matter to actual Hubble Space Telescope
photos we've used this photo before it's
the Hubble Ultra Deep Field you can't
see time in this still photo either but
by using the measured and the estimated
redshifts of these galaxies to determine
how far away they are the computer lets
us spread them out in time and zoom into
the picture redshift is a measure of how
much the light coming from distant
galaxies has been stretched by the
expansion of the universe since the
farther away a galaxy is the faster its
expanding away the redshift tells us its
distance as in the voyage we took to the
Virgo cluster in the first lecture we're
going to start out looking toward the
constellation Orion but this time we're
going to focus in on a region below and
to the right of it in the first part of
this video we will zoom in toward
regions that Hubble Space Telescope has
surveyed
we're now going to focus on a very dim
faint region that Space Telescope stared
into for more than two fill full weeks
in order to gather enough light to see
the famous and most distant galaxies
first we see the galaxies as if we're
looking at a photo in two dimensions and
notice some of them look very odd indeed
not at all like the nearby spiral and
elliptical galaxies now let's zoom in
first the nearby galaxies go sliding off
to the edge of the field the nearby
galaxies especially the big ones are
disk Alexei's like the Milky Way or
elliptical galaxies light from the ones
just disappearing now has been traveling
toward us for about 5 billion years
before the sun and earth formed now
about 8 billion years but as we zoom
deeper in the nature of the galaxies
changes we're no longer seeing big
galaxies like those near us now the
earliest galaxies those that formed in
the first two billion years after the
Big Bang are small and irregularly
shaped but very bright because they're
forming stars rapidly we think they're
ragged-looking because of these early
times the universe was a lot smaller
than it is now and the dark matter of a
forming galaxies was frequently
colliding with the dark matter of other
galaxies in this early bumper car era
the Hubble Ultra Deep Field showed the
galaxies in just a little pinpoint of
the sky now I want to show you the
large-scale distribution of galaxies is
mapped by the ongoing Sloan Digital Sky
Survey so this is the picture that we
looked at at the last lecture where we
had this trip across the local
supercluster to the Virgo cluster the
local supercluster in turn
is just a little tiny region at the
bottom of this big V this shows some of
the large-scale structure that's been
mapped by the Sloan Digital Sky Survey
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey has mapped
all of the reasonably bright galaxies in
certain directions that they're mapping
them in out to about 2 billion
light-years the really bright red
galaxies shown here in red out to about
6 billion light-years their distance
today and the quasars out to a distance
today of about 28 billion light years
let's look at how these galaxies are
distributed in space so we're backing
rapidly away from our region of the
universe we're about a billion
light-years out as these first luminous
red galaxies come in we're about two
billion light-years out the galaxies are
all piling up in front of each other in
the central region but off on the side
you can see that there are walls of
galaxies surrounding regions with hardly
any galaxies at all cosmic voids we call
them to get the three-dimensional image
of how these galaxies are distributed
though we have to rotate this
visualization and what you see is that
the mapped sections look like slices
through a sponge walls of galaxies
surrounding cosmic voids now the quasars
in blue
and now the cosmic background radiation
where the colors represent slight
differences in temperature we're looking
at the entire visible universe from the
outside something that can only be done
with the help of a computer
visualization
this video ends by showing the sphere of
the cosmic background radiation from the
outside as though we are outside they
are not part of the universe not inside
the sphere to the extent that this is a
helpful stats for scientists who are
gathering data this imagined standpoint
does serve its purpose but for the rest
of us it's extremely misleading about
reality we modern people both scientists
and non-scientists who lack the
intuitive sense of belonging to the
universe that people had in ancient
times we need to start visually
visualizing our universe from the inside
where we actually are otherwise we will
always misinterpret ourselves feeling as
though we're outside sensing a familiar
existential isolation and looking at a
universe in which we play no part so
let's introduce a new and more accurate
standpoint Joel and I call this symbol
the cosmic spheres of time these
concentric spheres don't represent just
space each sphere moving outward
represents an earlier and earlier time
in the history of the universe with our
galaxy as it is today at the center and
the earliest time the Big Bang
represented by the outermost sphere when
we look out into space we look back in
time why is that we see when light hits
our eyes carrying a picture of its
source light travels through space at a
fixed speed of 186,000 miles per second
it's very fast but it's finite when we
look through telescopes we see galaxies
as they were eons ago when the light
that's reaching our eyes now left them
the farther away a galaxy is the longer
its light has been travelling to get to
us and therefore we see it at an earlier
stage in the evolution of the universe
then we see the galaxies nearby us so we
are looking back in time when we look at
them
we are at the center of our past the
past is not over it's racing away from
us at the speed of light like ripples
from a pebble thrown into a pond but not
in circles in spheres spheres of time
the era when our Sun and Earth were
forming four and a half billion years
ago is still out there spherical II
surrounding our solar system our galaxy
and all the nearby superclusters far
beyond that is the era when the first
big galaxies formed these images are
taken from the Hubble Ultra Deep Field
and of course they're much larger than
the scale of this figure but what you'll
see is that most of these galaxies look
pretty much like the nearby galaxies
except as you get out close to the
sphere where the big galaxies are
starting to form but then this next fear
represents where bright galaxies first
started forming in the first billion
billion years of the universe or so and
these are all pictures of those odd
galaxies that you saw in the ultra deep
field that don't look anything like the
nearby galaxies beyond that is a region
that theory tells us is the cosmic dark
ages the period before bright galaxies
had formed earlier still lies the seer
of the cosmic background radiation and
at last the cosmic horizon the Big Bang
with telescopes we see galaxies as they
were millions and billions of years ago
but in the cosmic series of time we're
showing you where what they look like
then but placing them where they are now
because of the finite speed of light we
can't know what they look like now but
we can calculate where they are now with
theory once again the double dark theory
no scientific explanation that treats us
as objective observers of the universe
out there can never be satisfying and
what's more no such explanation can ever
be accurate because the
universe exists on all size scales and
on our scale where indisputably here and
we need to be explained the cosmic
spheres of time place us at the center
but it's still drawn as if they're up
there on the screen and here we all out
are out here looking at it so jump into
this picture in your imagination take
your place there at the center of the
symbol at today and then close the
spheres around yourself we are
physically immersed in the past of the
universe take a moment to absorb that
our place in the universe is not a
geographical place but a meaningful
place created by the interaction of
space-time light and consciousness
without consciousness after all there
would be no visible universe the cosmic
spirits of time are real because the
past is real we know that because
evidence of it in the form of light is
arriving constantly let me illustrate
this again with an image in the ancient
world when people needed to get a
message somewhere they had no instant
media so they had to send a runner and
that took time so imagine that a runner
were just arriving here today from
ancient Greece breathless with the news
that the Persians had just been defeated
at marathon and we were the first to
hear it from his lips messengers in
every form of radiation and speaking the
strangest languages anyone has ever
heard have been running for billions of
years toward the earth and are arriving
at our telescopes at every moment from
all over the universe with news of their
eras their ancient eras and our
generation is the first to hear them the
cosmological revolution of today is
human beings beginning to decode all
their languages understand the news and
pull the whole story together it's
everyone's story it took billions of
years for galaxies to form for stars to
form inside the gal
these for Stardust to become common
enough so that rocky planets could
evolve and then on at least one of those
rocky planets for life to evolve to the
complexity of beings like us who can be
flex on it all many billions of years
were required for the evolution of
intelligence stars continue to form and
some will be burning for trillions of
years there's no reason life could not
go on that long if the dark energy keeps
on accelerating the expansion of space
all these distant galaxies will
eventually disappear and our own local
Group of galaxies will become for our
very distant descendants the entire
visible universe the overwhelmingly rich
sky that we see in this photograph dense
with galaxies will be known to our
distant descendants only historically
the astronomical observations and
understandings that we pass on will be
an irreplaceable part of our heritage
and yet there are millions of people in
the United States today who believe that
the world was created 6,000 years ago as
is and that human beings have been on it
the entire time except for the first
five days there are millions of people
who believe that the end is near that
the rapture is coming but we have a new
story now we humans were not here at the
beginning and we're nowhere near the end
we live in the middle of time and in
lecture 3 will explore this discovery in
its practical implications we with the
other potential members of the cosmic
club of intelligent life are at the peak
of the cosmic density pyramid an
enormous base of material and phenomena
in the universe support our existence
and over time have made it possible
within the capstone that represents
Stardust the fraction that's associated
just with living things is extremely
tiny and within that extremely tiny
fraction the matter associated
specifically with intelligent life
anywhere in the universe is vanishingly
small and yet it's only that which looks
at and grasps this pyramid and the way
that time has constructed it it may even
just
to be our eyes we may be the only ones
the very human-looking I in the capstone
suggest mind or vision unquantifiable
things that transcend the issue of
quantity the I reminds us that
intelligence bursts out only from tiny
bits of Stardust intelligent life is the
rarest and most complex phenomenon we
know of in the entire universe to become
a cosmic society as we've said in the
beginning of this talk we need to
understand what we are and how we fit
into the universe but we also need it to
matter again the challenge is to know in
our bones that we are connected to the
universe that the evidence says exists
so now imagine that you have suddenly
lost your memory you look at yourself in
a mirror but there's only this moment
you're unaware of any past even the very
moment before this one you're solid your
cells are real your heart is pumping but
how you got to the spot on which you
stand you have no idea who are you
there's no answer you're not your family
background your personal history the
work you've done your hopes for the
future these don't exist you have no
family no associations you're like a
computer with hormones you've lost your
soul you're listening to the latest
music buying the latest improved
products and believing the latest media
interpretation of the world outside your
room this is all you know now instead
imagine yourself as a budding leaf at
the very tip of a long branch of an
enormous tree of time and send your
consciousness back through your stem and
branches at lightning speed down past
your parents and grandparents down the
countless generations before them
through your ancestors roaming from
continent to continent your primate
ancestors down through all the animals
that preceded them
back through the earliest life into a
single cell down into the complex
chemicals that made it possible down
into the molten planet and the forming
solar system the birth of your carbon
and oxygen and iron in exploding stars
far across the galaxy back to the
universal expansion to the creation of
your elementary particles in the Big
Bang this is not fantasy is a science
you are all this who you are is the sum
total of your history and how far back
you take that history how much of your
own identity you claim is up to you we
have an extraordinary and meaningful
place in the universe but only if it has
a place in us we hope to see you again
next Tuesday for lecture 3 this
cosmically pivotal moment thank you very
much
you